[Music]  you know we have a we have a song which  we teach in class to help people  remember the names of the major dynasty  right it really does help to know which  dynasty comes before which so it's we're  less concerned with the dates where we  are with the chronological order the  sequence of devices can you sing that  song I cannot sing it as well as you can  well shall we sing it together Changjo  Qin Han seongjo Qin Han suede hyung song  sui Tang song you and Ming Qing Republic  you and making Republic mouths or Dome  mouths or don't  so if you sing this song once a day you  will always remember the sequence of  Chinese dynasties it works it's  guaranteed you will also drive your  friends and family crazy it's true  you